Speaker 1: All right. Let's talk about a couple
of other little side stories that are taking place
here. One of the interesting kind of contrasts or
conflicts that has arisen over the last few days.
Is the contradiction between anger that Donald
Trump has been arrested and the claim that this
is really great for Trump? Well, if it's great for
Trump, then wouldn't someone be happy about it?
But yet all of the magazines are furious and
they say this is the biggest and most injust
miscarriage of the justice system. If it's great
for Trump, then you'd think someone would be happy
about it. So this reached a sort of fever pitch
yesterday. And I'll just give you one example,
although there are many. Newsmax anchor Greg Kelly
said that while under arrest in police custody,
Trump looks even more presidential, if you can
imagine it. You know, sit up there of visiting
with with Naito or on during a state dinner with
the prime minister of Japan. No, no, no, no, no,
no, no. You are at your most presidential while
under arrest in a ratty New York City courtroom.
Here is Greg Kelly. Listen to him say it.
Speaker 2: President Donald Trump, this was
technically in police custody today. Yeah.
Going from processing into the arraignment.
And somehow he looks even more presidential.
Speaker 1: The brown nosing is
giving me cringe. Greg, I'm sorry.
Speaker 2: Serious. I mean, we're talking eye
of the tiger. This is why so many people are drawn
to him. He fights. And by the way, this is this is
all nonsense, right? I've seen the indictment and
it's a joke. It's even sillier than we thought.
Oh, by the way, could you imagine Joe Biden being
in this situation? Could he survive? Could be
thrived. Donald Trump just gave an amazing speech
in Mar a Lago tonight. We'll get to the details
in a moment, Some highlights. But first, the
Democrats, they wanted this image to be totally
different. They wanted the defeated broken man or
under arrest. They wanted somebody like like this
guy, DSK, when he was arrested. I mean, that looks
pretty bad. Or this guy who allegedly, I think,
killed his parents, his father. I mean, that's
the same table that Donald Trump was sitting at
today. Or this guy recently arrested. I mean, this
is what they thought Donald Trump would look like.
Instead, you know what? It looked like he was
back on The Apprentice. There's nothing damaging
about these photos. In fact, it's damaging to the
people who put him there. Okay. It's they will be
exposed. In fact, they already are exposed.
Speaker 1: Right. So listen here. Here's the
bottom line. There can be there can be truths that
seemingly conflict with each other but don't. So,
for example, I believe it is true that Trump's
arrest helps Trump in the Republican primary, and
it helps him in two ways. I do believe that there
are Republicans who have been kind of disaffected
by Trump who maybe were planning to support
someone else or not vote at all in the primary,
and some of them will indeed be activated by
Donald Trump's arrest because they've been
convinced it's unfair or whatever the case may
be. So that will help Trump in the primary. The
other way it will help Trump in the primary is
who on earth has mentioned Ron DeSantis in the
last week? Ron DeSantis, his name, which was very
much front and center in the news, is essentially
gone. So good for Trump as far as the primary is
concerned. If Trump wins the primary, this does
not seem to be good for Trump. And in particular,
if there is another indictment, this is the exact
type of chaos that surrounds Trump that doesn't
get him a single new vote in the general election.
And remember, Trump lost by like 8 million votes
in 2020. And so if he's going to win in 2024 now,
yes, granted, the the difference in the states
that made a difference is a much smaller number.
That's always the case. If Trump is going to win
in 2024, he needs to find some new votes or the
Democratic turnout needs to be lower, which may
be. And we'll talk about that on a different day.
I don't believe that this arrest gets Trump any
new general election votes. So these people are
really parodies of themselves. This is the new
thing. It's great for Trump. Trump looked so
presidential sitting there at the defense table,
certainly in the eye of the beholder. To me,
he looked angry in the video where he was entering
the courtroom and he looks kind of dejected while
sitting there at the defense table. But everyone
is going to see in it to some degree what they
want to see. And I understand that we'll see
ultimately what this does for Donald Trump.